now this may not be a general election
but these polls and the results could
prove incredibly important
across much of britain but before we get
to that let's take a moment to consider
what's going on and the short answer is
quite a lot actually there are depending
on how you count it actually seven
or eight separate things happening here
so first of all
you've got the scottish and welsh
parliament elections they happen every
five years there's the english council
elections the local elections in this
case there's actually two years worth of
them bundled into one because last
year's cancelled
due to covert you've got the london
assembly elections and the vote for the
london
mayor those were also postponed and
you've got another 12 elected mayors
across various metropolitan and
regional areas of england you've got
police and crime commissioner elections
too and as if
that weren't all enough you've also got
a parliamentary by-election to elect a
new mp
for hartlepool to make it more
complicated i'm afraid
many of these different elections
involve slightly different voting
systems so
hartlepool that's simple as with general
elections the candidate with the most
votes
wins but the scottish and welsh
elections they involve something called
the additional
member system you vote once for a
candidate in your local constituency and
a second time
for a party those second votes go
towards a regional list
of members of these parliaments it's a
form of proportional representation the
idea being
to ensure that smaller parties get
represented in the parliaments and it
makes getting a majority very difficult
indeed though
not impossible the additional member
system that's also used for the london
assembly election but
not for the london mayor that election
uses a different voting system the
supplementary vote where you choose
a first and a second choice candidate
it's not proportional it's not a
proportional representation
but it's designed to find a candidate
who most people either want or
kind of want same system supplementary
vote for the directly elected mayors
elsewhere around the uk and
the police and crime commissioners too
you get the idea
seven or eight elections three different
voting systems three days maybe more
of counting as we start to piece
together the latest picture
of politics around great britain